one of the reasons I gave you I gave
Alex a book um uh which is the topic of
the book is what happens when scientists
basically stray off the path of
technical knowledge and start to weigh
in on politics and societal issues in
this case philosophers philosophers but
he actually talks in this book about
like Einstein he talks about the nuclear
age and Einstein he talks about the
physicists uh actually uh doing doing uh
very similar things at the time the book
is when reason goes on holiday
philosophers and politics by uh Nevin
and it's just a story it's a story
there's there are other books on this
topic but this is a new one that's
really good it's just a story of what
happens when experts in a certain domain
decide to weigh in and become basically
social engineers and uh and the
political um you know basically
political advisors and it's just a story
of just unending catastrophe
right and I think that's what happened
with covet again
yeah I found this book a highly
entertaining and eye-opening read filled
with the amazing anecdotes of
irrationality and craziness by famous
recent philosophers after you read this
book you will not look at Einstein the
same oh boy yeah don't destroy my heroes
anymore
um I'm sorry you shouldn't read the book
all right but here's the thing the AI
the AI risk people they don't even have
the covet model
at least not that I'm aware of no like
there's not even the equivalent of the
government model they don't even have
the spaghetti code
they've got a theory and a warning and
this and that and like if you ask like
okay well here's here's the I mean the
ultimate example is okay how do we know
right how do we know that an AI is
running away like how do we know that
the film takeoff thing is actually
happening and the only answer that any
of these guys have given that I've ever
seen is oh it's when the loss rate the
loss function in the training drops
right that's when you need to like shut
down the data center right and it's like
well that's also what happens when
you're successfully training a model
like
like what what even is this is not
science this is not it's not anything
it's not a model it's not anything
there's nothing to arguing with it it's
like you know pushing Jello like there's
what do you even respond to uh so did
you put pushback on that I don't think
they have
good metrics of yeah wonderful is
happening but I think it's possible to
have that like I just just as you speak
now I mean it's possible to imagine
there could be measures it's been 20
years no for sure but it's been only
weeks since we had a big enough
breakthrough in language models we can
start to actually have this the thing is
the AI Doomer stuff didn't have any
actual systems to really work with and
now there's real systems you can start
to analyze like how does this stuff go
wrong and I think you kind of agree that
there is a lot of risks that we can
analyze the benefits outweigh the risks
in many cases but the risks are not
existential yes well not not in the food
not in the phone paper clip now so let
me okay there's another sleight of hand
that you just alluded to there's another
sleight of hand that happens which is
very I think I'm very good at the
sleight of hand thing which is very not
scientific so the book super
intelligence right which is like the
Nick bostrom's book which is like the
origin of a lot of this stuff which was
written you know whatever 10 years ago
or something
so he does this really fascinating thing
in the book which is he basically says
um uh there are many possible routes to
machine intelligence um to artificial
intelligence and he describes all the
different routes to artificial
intelligence all the different possible
everything from biological augmentation
through to you know all these different
things
um one of the ones that he does not
describe is large language models
because of course the book was written
before they were invented and so they
didn't exist
in the book he just he describes them
all and then he proceeds to treat them
all as if they're exactly the same thing
he presents them all as sort of an
equivalent risk to be dealt with in an
equivalent way to be thought about the
same way and then the risk the
quote-unquote risk that's actually
emerged is actually a completely
different technology than he was even
imagining and yet all of his theories
and beliefs are being transplanted by
this movement like straight on this new
technology and so again like there's no
other area of science or technology
where you do that yeah like when you're
dealing with like organic chemistry
versus inorganic chemistry you don't
just like say oh with respect to like
either one basically maybe you know
growing up and eating the world or
something like they're just going to
operate the same way like you don't but
you can start talking about like as as
we get more and more actual systems that
start to get more and more intelligent
you can start to actually have more
scientific arguments here like you know
high level you can talk about the threat
of autonomous weapon systems back before
we had any Automation in in the military
and that would be like very fuzzy kind
of logic but the more and more you have
drones that are becoming more and more
autonomous you can start imagining okay
what does that actually look like and
what's the actual threat of autonomous
weapon systems How does it go wrong and
still it's it's very vague but you start
to get a sense of like all right
um it should probably be illegal or
wrong or not allowed to do like
Mass deployment of fully autonomous
drones that are doing aerial strikes oh
no on large areas I think it should be
required right so that's no no no I
think if you're required that only
aerial vehicles are automated
okay so you want to go the other way I
want to go the other way so that okay I
think it's obvious that the machine is
going to make a better decision than the
human pilot
I think it's obvious that it's in the
best interest of both the attacker and
the defender and Humanity at large if
machines are making more of these
decisions and not people I think people
make terrible decisions in times of War
but like there's a there's ways this can
go wrong too right well the words go
terribly wrong now
this goes back to the this is that whole
thing about like this Ultra it is the
self-driving car need to be perfect
versus does it need to be better than
the human driver yeah does the automated
drone need to be perfect or does it need
to be better than a human pilot at
making decisions under enormous amounts
of stress and uncertainty yeah well the
on average right the the worry
that AI folks have is the runaway
they're going to come alive right then
again that's the sleight of hand right
or not not come alive well no hold on a
second you're becoming do you lose
control but then they're going to
develop goals of their own they're going
to develop them under their own they're
going to develop their own right no more
more like uh Chernobyl style meltdown
like uh just bugs in the code
accidentally you know Force you the the
results in the bombing of like large
civilian areas okay into a degree that's
not possible
um in in the current uh military
strategies well actually we've been
doing a lot of mass bombings to cities
for a very long time yes and a lot of
civilians die a lot of civilians died
and if you watch the documentary The Fog
of War McNamara it's been a big part of
it talking about the firebombing of the
Japanese cities yeah bringing them
straight to the ground right the
devastation in Japan American Military
uh firebombing the cities in Japan was a
considerably bigger Devastation than the
use of nukes right so we've been doing
that for a long time we also did that
Germany by the way Germany did that to
us right like that's an old tradition
the minute we got airplanes we started
doing indiscriminate bombing so one of
the things we're still doing it the
modern U.S uh military can do with
technology with automation but
technology more broadly is uh higher and
higher Precision strikes yeah well so
Precision is obviously and this is the
the jdam right so there's this big
Advance this big Advance um called the
JDM which basically was strapping a GPS
transceiver to uh to a to an unguided
bomb and turning it into a guided guided
bomb and yeah that's great like look
that's been a big advance but and that's
like a baby version of this question
which is okay do you want like the human
pilot like guessing where the bomb's
gonna land or do you want like the
machine like getting the bottom twist
destination
that's a baby version of the question
the next version of the question is do
you want the human or the machine
deciding whether to drop the bomb
everybody just assumes the human's going
to do a better job for what I think are
fundamentally suspicious reasons
emotional psychological reasons I think
it's very clear that the machine's going
to do a better job making that decision
because the humans making that making
that decision are god-awful just
terrible yeah right and so so yeah so
this is the this is the thing and then
let's get to the there's can I one more
slide of hand okay please I'm a magician
you could say one more sleight of hand
these things are going to be so smart
right that they're going to be able to
destroy the world and wreak havoc and
like do all this stuff and plan and do
all the stuff and evade us and have all
their secret things and their secret
factories and all this stuff but they're
so stupid that they're going to get like
tangled up in their code and that's
they're not going to come alive but
there's going to be some bug that's
going to cause them to like turn us all
into paper like that they're not gonna
they're gonna be genius in every way
other than the actual bad goal
and it's just like and that's just like
a like ridiculous like discrepancy and
and and you can prove this today you can
actually address this today for the
first time with llms which is you can
actually ask llms to resolve uh moral
dilemmas yeah so you can create the
scenario you know dot dot dot this that
this that this that what would you as
the AI do in the circumstance and they
don't just say Destroy All Humans
Destroy All Humans they will give you
actually very nuanced moral practical
trade-off oriented answers so we
actually already have the kind of AI
that can actually like think this
through and can actually like you know
reason about goals well the the hope is
that AGI or like a very super
intelligent systems have some of the
Nuance that llms have and the intuition
is they most likely will because even
these llms have the Nuance uh elements
are really this is actually worth worth
um spending moment on LMS are really
interesting to have moral conversations
with and that
is I didn't expect I'd be having a moral
conversation with a machine in my
lifetime well and let's remember we're
not really having a conversation with a
machine where we're having a
conversation with the entirety of the
collective intelligence of the human
species exactly yeah correct but it's
possible to imagine autonomous weapon
systems that are not using llms but if
they're smart enough to be scary
why are they not smart enough to be wise
like that's the part where it's like I
don't know how you get the one without
the other is it possible to be super
intelligent without being Super Wise
well you're again you're back to that I
mean then you're back to a classic
autistic computer right like you're back
to just like a blind rule follower I've
got this like core is the paper clip
thing I've got this core Rule and I'm
just going to follow it to the end of
the Earth and it's like well but
everything you're going to be doing
execute that rule is going to be super
genius level that humans aren't going to
be able to counter it's just a it's a
it's a mismatch in the definition of
what the system is capable of unlikely
but not impossible I think but again
here you get to like okay like no I'm
not saying when it's unlikely but not
impossible if it's unlikely that means
the the fear should be correctly
calibrated extraordinary claims require
extraordinary proof